hey what's going on everybody it's ETA
Prime back here again it's been a little
while since we've seen a single slot
lowprofile GPU hit the mark in but today
we're going to be taking a look at a
brand new one this is the sparkle Eco
Arc A310 and it's a low power single
slot low profile card and you know when
it comes to these low profiles we've
only got a couple of choices you know if
you want to do a little bit of gaming
the gt1030 which is definitely getting
dated and the radon RX 6400 so I'm
actually really glad to get my hands on
a new lowprofile single slot card so
obviously what we've got here for super
small form factor now you could
definitely add this to a larger PC if
you wanted to doesn't require any extra
power total board power here for the
overall GPU itself 50 Watts but while
you're running at the stock clocks this
thing's only going to pull about 32
watts like most of these single slots
we've got 4 GB of vram here and it's
based on Intel Arc it's the A310 we do
have a little bit of tweaking and tuning
tun in that we can do from the Intel art
Control Center and I'll show you that
once we get into it and when it comes to
outputting video from this card we've
got HDMI and two mini display ports so
they wanted to keep this really small
but we've got three displays out of the
A310 here not too bad it is PCI e8x 4.0
and the other specs are as followed over
on the sparkle website it states that
the GPU clock is 1,00 MHz but this boost
way over it's actually double what we're
looking at here and we'll get into
Windows I'll show you exactly what I'm
talking about this has six XE cores six
Ray tracing units 96 Intel xmx engines
and 96 XE Vector engines we've also got
4 GB of
gddr6 again it's pcie 4.0 8X and total
board power is 50 wats but when you're
running this you're only going to see a
power draw of around 32 to 34 at the
stock power limit so I've recently been
on the hunt for a single slot lowprofile
card specifically for this ms01 from Min
Forum I love this little workstation PC
and as soon as I open it up you'll see
we do have a PCI ex16 slot really only
enough room for a single slot lowprofile
card and this A310 fits right in here
perfectly now when they initially
announced the ms01 they did show off a
video with an A2000 but it was a
modified A2000 from Nvidia with an
aftermarket single slot cooler I'm in
the market for one of those I'd love to
put that card in here but until then I
was looking for something to kind of get
me by and the sparkle Eco A310 is only
coming in at around
$99 fits perfectly in this little setup
and I know the CPU here we've got more
than enough power I've got the 13th gen
I9 version of the
ms01 and I'm really hoping to see some
decent gaming performance now I
personally have not tested the A310 I've
tested most of the other art cards on
the market right now this is coming in
as one of their lower-end versions but
at $99 if you're in a pinch for a small
form factor low profile single slot card
it might work out all right so first
things first we've got this card in the
super small form factor ms01 from minus
Forum there are a couple different
variants but this one here happens to
have the Intel I9 13900 H I've got 32
gigs of ddr5 running at 5200 MHz and of
course we're going to be using this
Intel Arc A310 low profile only 4 gigs
of vram and what I've noticed here is
with a lot of these games it is digging
in into the system memory which will
hurt performance cuz a lot of these
newer games do need more than 4 gigs of
VR fully up to date here uh with the
Intel Arc drivers and luckily since
we've got a desktop variant we can
actually do a little bit of tuning here
so basically what you're really going to
want to do with this little card here is
just give it a little more I've been
messing around with the settings GPU
performance boost I've just gone up to
50 and I've taken the GPU voltage offset
up just a little bit to help out that
performance performance boost now you
really will have to kind of experiment
with this because all cards are going to
be different all systems are going to be
different there's a chance you could go
a bit higher with this with no GPU
voltage offset but uh you really got to
kind of just mess around with it see
what's stable what's not but luckily we
do have this option here to get a little
more out of the A310 I'm going to run
furmark this is going to stress that GPU
out for
us and as you can see right here our GPU
clock is at
2,350 MHz so that's well over the
advertised 1,000 MHz and even without
changing the settings in art control
panel it still boost up to
2350 and really we're up to 38.4 because
we've done a little bit of that offset
little bit of performance boost this is
normally around 32 watts just across the
board if you're not using any kind of
tweaking or tuning with this card itself
so yeah there is a little more that we
can get out of this and the first thing
I wanted to show off were some
benchmarks that I ran on this system 3D
Mark night raid
7,44 and this one here isn't looking as
good as I thought it would be I mean
it's kind of right on par with the 780m
igpu but moving over to fire strike
started to look a little better coming
in with an
8,037 still pretty low in terms of
running this Benchmark on a dedicated
GPU in 2024 but it's a really cheap
lowprofile single slot GPU and the final
Benchmark we have here is time spy with
a
3,722 was hoping to see a little better
performance in these synthetic
benchmarks but that's what they are
they're synthetic now it's time to move
over to some real world gaming and see
how this A310 really
performs first one on the list is Forza
Horizon 5 and that's because it's
definitely an easier game to run on
these lower-end gpus we're at 1080p
medium with no XC SS now we could also
add FSR if you wanted to or go with
Intel's X SS we didn't need any scaling
here at medium 1080P and if you take a
look at After Burner up up in the top
left hand corner you can see that GPU
memory is at 5 gigs we are digging into
system memory right now remember this
A310 only has 4 gigs of
gddr6 next up we've got Doom Eternal
really great performance medium 1080p
100% resolution scale definitely over 60
we had an average of 74 FPS by the end
of this run here I mean it's really
playable but again this is a little bit
of an older one and one that's pretty
easy to run on these systems so I
expected we'd see some playable
performance here definitely
is I also wanted to test shadow of the
Tomb Raider so I just used the built-in
Benchmark here 1080p medium and I do
have XCS set to Performance this didn't
Faire as well as I thought it would
because uh by the end of this run we
only had an average of 63 now we are
over that 60 hump but it would have been
nice to be up in the 70s or 80s with a
little card like
this GTA 5 is one that I still go back
to for single player I did some
multiplayer for a while but I wanted to
test it here and at 1080 High we had an
average of 134 FPS looking like these
older games are going to run really well
on the A310 so I mean we've got a lot of
games that are going to be totally
playable on this card and given $99
price tag for a new card that'll fit
these small form factor PCS looking
pretty decent so far not top the line by
any means but Mortal Kombat 1 did much
better than I thought it would medium
1080p XC SS is set to balance now
without XC SS on this is around 42 FPS
with just the medium 1080p so having
that resolution scale really helps out
with this but the fighting games that
I've tested so far do work well on the
ark
A310 po world was one that I didn't
think was going to perform that well now
unfortunately we don't have access to
FSR or xss yet in the game without any
modifications so I did have to drop this
down to 900p low we got an average of 61
FPS and you will see it drop down below
60 but for the most part I mean we're
over that hump there and it's not too
bad if you're in a pinch you could
definitely get by but we've still got
some resolution we could take down you
could always go down to 720 on a card
like
this and the final game I wanted to test
was cyberpunk 277 so at 1080 low with XS
set to Performance you can get an
average of around 61 I wanted a little
more out of it so I went down to 900p
low with XE SS set to balance and we got
an average of 71 FPS given the state of
Arc and this game here I think this is
some pretty decent performance given
that we're working with a low powerered
Intel GPU and Intel is constantly
updating these drivers so uh just a
couple weeks ago I can guarantee you
that the A310 was not performing like it
is here in cyberpunk 2077 but with those
later Arc drivers or those newer Arc
drivers we're seeing playable
performance at
900p going into this with the sparkle
A310 I knew we weren't going to see 4K
performance out of this card and that's
not what I was going for it's a $99
lowprofile single slot card that can
play some games pretty decently at 1080
some of the newer stuff you might want
to drop down to 900p but given the
limited availability of the single Slot
lowprofile Cards for a small form factor
PC like the ms01 this could be a good
choice to get by until you can find
something El
now one thing I mentioned at the
beginning a lowprofile single slot
cooler for the A2000 and they're out
there but uh the price on them is pretty
high a little hard to get soon as I can
get one I will be putting one inside of
this PC here but for now I think I could
stick to the A310 and have a pretty
decent time with the
ms01 but that's going to wrap it up for
this video I will have at least one more
coming up with the ark A310 I do think
we can get a little more out of this
when we pair it up with a different kind
of system and I'll talk about more of
that in the next video but if you're
interested in learning a little more I
will leave some links down below you can
pick this up over on Amazon I believe
New Egg also has it and if you want to
see anything else in the next video with
this graphics card let me know in the
comments below but that's it for this
one like always thanks for
watching